- You would this at this
point there’s nothing
left to make us uncomfortable.
You’d be wrong.
(exciting orchestral music)
- We have not gotten naked in a long time,
so I guess it’s back to the basics.
- Bathing suits can make you feel sexy,
they can also make you
feel super objectified.
- It’s good that we’re
doing this, cause women
have to wear ridiculous
swimsuits all the time.
- You have to have a lot of confidence
to put your body out there like that.
(scoffs)
Luckily I do!
- Okay...
Well this is just like a speed...
Oh no!
- They forgot about the butt.
- Hi!
- I don’t like that this
is where we’re starting.
- You know why else Ned’s gonna love this?
It’s red.
- I love red.
- It’s my favorite color because red...
- [Both] Rhymes with Ned!
- When you’re wearing a
thing that has your butt open
(sighs) you’re probably
gonna see a butthole!
- It looks like a very normal speedo.
- This is the definition
of business in the front...
And party in the back.
- I keep on spinning.
- It’s like suspenders for your butt!
- All I can think of
when I wear this is Ned,
which is really disturbing.
- You could play ‘Are
These Boobs or Butts?’
- I would try and get into the
pool as quickly as possible.
- Nobody look at my butt,
nobody look at my butt.
- Doesn’t that look like boobs?
Doesn’t it?
Tell me that doesn’t look like boobs.
- Men don’t get enough
opportunities to have cleavage.
- What’s it like to squat completely?
- If you dropped something
and had to bend down
to pick it up your butt would
be like, “Hi Spongebob!”
- There’s a lot of things in the water.
You don’t want to give them
an extra orifice to, like,
discover.
- I’m looking for something
that’ll make me feel more
uncomfortable than being naked.
- Keep on spinning.
- And right now this makes me feel great.
- This is the Borat.
Does it matter which side’s
the front or the back,
cause they both look impossibly tiny.
- What even is this?
- Who can fill this dick pocket?
- Oh, hm...
- It’s just pulling my dick up.
- Is it supposed to go up your butt?
Is it supposed to be a thong?
- An unexpected but not unwanted feature.
- How do you wear this?
- We may have made a
mistake making this video.
- You shouldn’t be able to do that.
No one...
This is gross!
- The back is really just...
Oh no.
- Of all the things for
this outfit to cover,
why are the nipples the thing?
- If you’re a woman,
you’re very stressed out
about keeping your bits covered.
- I think everyone should
have their nipples out
without judgement.
- It’s revolting.
I’ve never found myself revolting before.
And I’ve vomited on myself.
- The shape is cool, it
does emphasize a man’s V.
- When you go swimming your
pants usually come off that way.
Here, boom! (laughs)
Oh no!
- All eyes are
leading straight to the money-maker.
- I mean, I definitely feel objectified.
So mission accomplished!
- This is like the leash
with the body holder,
so you’re not pulling your dog’s neck.
- This is getting into some kinky shit.
- First things first, let’s
let that string disappear
inside my butt crack; it’s gone forever.
- One size fits some people.
- Very fine line between my dick going...
(honking noise)
And my dick going (thuds) yeah!
- It’s weird cause this is
pulling the front, but I want...
Oops, side ball.
- I kind of wish I had this for prom.
That would’ve made prom
a lot more interesting.
- Whoa, see? Side ball.
- This feels more like a sex
outfit than a swim outfit.
- I want this to be low. Side ball!
- Oh my goodness!
There are kids at this beach!
- You know what, no
shark is ever gonna think
you’re a seal in this.
It’s gonna be like, “Eugh!”
- I feel like a very, very
revealing butler in a porn.
- I bet Zach is feeling
pretty cute right now.
- I kind of like this one.
I think it’s pretty funny.
- Master, would you like
your cake today, sir?
(laughter)
(groans)
You just threw me a headband.
- This looks like one leg of an outfit.
- A penis slingshot?
- Extra large?
- I’ve heard about this.
Seen a lot of pictures.
- This is just not something
you wear in public.
Also it’s terrible fashion.
- Half my shaft is out, and one full nut.
Just hanging out.
- Everything’s just kind of leaning a bit.
It’s all just...
- What about
the pubic hair that you
have, because you’re a human?
- You need to do some serious man-scaping
if you want to wear this.
- Why was this made?
I don’t know, why are
there serial killers?
- I feel more naked than
if I were actually naked.
- This looks like a mistake.
It looks like a piece of balloon
got caught in my butt after it popped.
- G string.
Nude as fuck.
- Hello?
Hey honey.
I’m on a Try Guys shoot right now.
Can I call you back?
- It’s like my dick broke its wrist and
and has to wear a sling for the month.
- The dick is what it’s
grabbing onto to stay on,
and the dick is an elastic thing itself.
God forbid you get a boner in this!
- I love you too!
Bye.
That was my wife.
I’ll tell her about it later.
- Here, throw me another one.
- It’s a bummer that I had to go this far
to realize how
uncomfortable a bathing suit
might make you feel.
- Ta-da, fixed it!
- Game, set, match.
- My final thought
about this one is it can
go fuck off and die!
- I don’t think there’s
an intelligent conclusion
to be drawn from this.
- If there’s a bathing suit
that make you feel good
about yourself and make you feel sexy,
that’s awesome.
But this definitely does not
make me feel comfortable.
- If I went to a remote beach
where it was just me and my wife:
heck yes I’d wear some of these!
- There are way better
ways to feel and look sexy
than these swimsuits.
Leave a little to the imagination.
- I think we’re done here.
- I just saw Zach’s penis.
(laughing)
- Sorry!
- Yeah, I accidentally showed
Eugene my dick already.
- I can still see your—
I know, it’s...
- Your dick is out.
- I like that we sort of look like
awful power rangers!
- Oh, we do look like the power rangers!
- Yeah, really awful ones.
- I hate this one. I hate this video.
- You look so handsome.
- I can see his butt.
(laughing)
- My butt ate way more of
that string than yours.